wenn mehr als 10.000 teilnehmer durch
die innenstadt von hannover marschieren
und tanzen dann ist schützenfest um die
200.000 zuschauer sind alleine an diesem
tag gekommen trotz temperaturen von 37
grad celsius
das zehntägige fest gilt als größtes
schützenfest der welt
mittendrin die schützenkönigin lisa
marie müller
die 19-jährige ist dieses jahr meisterin
im schießsport wettbewerb geworden
alle halten zusammen egal dass welche
vereinbart ist wenn man in uniform auf
den platz geht ist man einfach eine
große familie das ist unglaublich
die schützenvereine waren im neunzehnten
jahrhundert politisch engagierte
bürgermilizen heute sind es reine
sportvereinen denn deutschland hat im
vergleich zu anderen ländern sehr
strenge waffengesetze
das hannoveraner schützenfest geht auf
eine 500 jahre alte tradition zurück
touristen gibt es wenige vor allem
einheimische suchen hier eine pause vom
alltag
die deutschen feste zeichneten sich
immer durch etwas aus was vielleicht mit
deutscher gemütlichkeit einhergeht der
idee dass man sich so gibt wie man ist
dass man so für einen kurzen moment
diese ganzen zwänge die auf einem lassen
dass man die mal kurz über bord wirft
sacha szabo ist soziologe und autor
mehrerer bücher über volksfeste 9900
volksfeste werden in deutschland gezählt
viele haben einen kirchlichen ursprung
und manche sind mehr als 1000 jahre alt
samt lokalen bier oder wein und
regionalen trachten und kostümen
hinzukommen imbiss buden und
fahrgeschäfte musik und tanz haben sie
mit anderen festen auf der welt
gemeinsam anderes hingegen ist typisch
deutsch zum beispiel das schunkeln und
egal ob auf dem dorf oder in der stadt
die volksfeste haben vor allem eine
funktion
eine gemeinschaft zu erzeugen und diese
gemeinschaft bildende funktion ist sehr
wichtig auch für die identität jedes
einzelnen der sich jetzt als teilnehmer
während diesem fest als teil von einem
größeren ganzen empfindet das münchner
oktoberfest ist mit abstand das
berühmteste deutsche volksfest und das
weltweit größte es zieht jedes jahr mehr
als sechs millionen besucher an
und es hat bayerische dirndl lederhosen
und bier in symbole für traditionelle
deutsche kultur an sich verwandelt nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg als jetzt die
amerikaner als besatzungsmacht in bayern
waren exportierten sie nun diese art
bayerischer lebensfreude in die ganze
welt das heißt international wurde jetzt
das oktoberfest zu einem synonym für
deutsche feierkultur viele feste
zelebrieren die jahreszeiten wie das
baumblütenfest zum höhepunkt der
obstbaumblüte strömen hunderttausende
besucher in das ländliche werder bei
berlin
jede region feiert das ihre auf dem
hamburger hafenfest ist es die
schifffahrt in den anbaugebieten
deutschlands sind ist die weine
irreführender name der dürkheimer
wurstmarkt er gilt als das größte
weinfest der welt
es gibt auch zahlreiche kleine regionale
weinfeste zum beispiel in freiburg der
heimatstadt des soziologen sascha wo für
ihn sind die feste immer wieder
interessante forschungs gegenstände
denn hier feiern menschen aus allen
bevölkerungsschichten auch wenn manche
die volksfeste als niedere vergnügen
belächeln
tatsächlich ist aber die kulturelle
funktion und auch der kulturelle wert in
diese feste erlauben historisch sie
historisch verbürgt sehr wertvoll und
eigentlich auch ein kulturgut das gar
nicht genug gewürdigt wird
zurück in hannover feste wie diese
gehören für viele einfach dazu sie
verbinden damit erinnerungen an
gemeinschaftsgefühl an familien ausflüge
an die erste liebe an gebrannte mandeln
und softeis und für lisa marie müller
und die anderen mitglieder der
schützenvereine ist das fest der
höhepunkt des jahres
ausnahmezustand man macht sich jeden tag
mann zieht seine uniform an
man steht ja schon heraus musikschau und
ein bisschen dazu und schon sind die
alltagssorgen vergessen